welcome to Paris Joseph
this year I fear this will not be a kind
place to such a boy
boy has talent but one in particular
that is exceptional very well
[Music]
I realized the more I exiled the less I
was alone
we were always so competitive
the show-off who spoiled Mozart's
concert May I play with you monsieur
I hope this won't be embarrassing for
you
who the hell is that
you are quite a remarkable man Joseph
I'm Marie Antoinette queen of France
hereby anoint you Chevalier any other
country man of your color would not be
wearing such fine clothes one day the
whole world will know me and of course
the music will be spectacular
bold
[Music]
you don't belong here you're a party
trick repet playing the violin that is
all
you know why the best
you were playing a dangerous game friend
you forget your place but break his
hands
the world is painful for us my son but
there is always
the choice
to fight I am putting on a concert that
is fun the revolution
you cannot afford to make any more
enemies
[Music]
you you'd be more influential than you
know leverage it
Filipino New France you cannot topple
what has been ordained by God
not everything is about you people
[Music]